الحديث عن هذه المواجهه لا ينتهي احدث
حلقاته الاتهام للصين باجراء ما وصف بانه
بروفا للغزوه المحتمل لاعاده تايوان
للسيطره
ولعقود طويله سنتحدث هنا مشاهدينا عن فتره
ما قبل الانترنت وهي التي يعيشها حاليا
ارخبيل تايواني نائم بالقرب من السواحل
الصينيه هنا مثلا في جزيره دونكينج
الصغيره التابعه لتايوان يعيش المواطنين
نموذجا لما يمكن ان يحدث في حال وقوع هجوم
صيني انقطع الانترنت فانعزل الارخبيل عن
العالم والاتهامات دائما موجهه لسفينه شحن
صينيه قطعت كابلات اتصالات تحت البحر تربط
دونجين بالجزيره التايوانيه الام ويمتد
اربعه عشر كابلا بحريا من تايوان بعضها
مدفون على بعد حوالي سته اقدام تقع البحر
لتوفير خدمات الانترنت والاتصالات للجزيره
النائيه حرب اوكرانيا مثلا سبق ان اظهرت
مدى اهميه الانترنت لدوله تواجهه هجوما
فاذا قطعت الصين اتصالات تايوان في حاله
الحرب سيكون التعتيم على ما يجري هناك
اسهل على حتى الان ليس لدى تايوان القدره
بمفردها على اصلاح الكابلات المعطله تحت
سطح البحر وتعتمد بدلا من ذلك على
متعاقدين من القطاع الخاص ليستغرق اصلاح
الضرر عده اسابيع تايوان اقرت بانها تبحث
عن حلول وقالت وزاره الشؤون الرقميه هناك
انها اجرت ابحاثا حول استخدام الانترنت
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه في حالات الطوارئ
مثل مثلا خدمه ستار لينك التي تقدمها شركه
سبيس اكس وتخطط الوزاره لتجربتها في اكثر
من 700 موقع